*Markimoo noises*
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to "Human Fall Flat"
The horrible monstrosity that is known as me is back again once again to haunt your dreams!
So I'm gonna continue on this way
Well SHIT I was not- FUUUUUCK! My BALLS!
ok
I wasn't supposed to do that! I'm supposed to actually climb up on the ledge because that would be the smart thing to do
So let's put this back, to where it was supposed to be
And then NOT douche it up with my stupidity
So I'm gonna get to the end of this level, you're gonna see me get there
In MONTAGE style because I'm not gonna subject you guys to my own horrible-ness more than I have to
I mean, there's nothing I like more than subjecting you to how stupid I am and bad at games
but, RIGHT NOW I WANNA BE SERIOUS ABOUT THIS and we're gonna make some progress
HUBHRRAY!!
Hurray!
And...launch!
Make it!
Oh, I didn't even need my arms!
I can do this with no arms
Human fall flat!
HUP!~
Oh I needed my arms there
Saved myself real good
Alright new area, show me what you got!
Is that my chateau?
Is that the place I live and this is *laughs* this is the impossibility of how it is to get there?
Oh you know, nice quiet neighborhood
Very uh, low tra- what the hell? OK!
That's a physic-based doo-dad!
I'm gonna make it! I'm gonna make it! I'm gonna make it! I'm gonna make it!
HUP!~
Yessth! I'm the best! Ok
So I made that...
I don't think I can make this.
Maybe, maybe if I thrust my belly upon it
and my grundle,
it'll push it off into the abyss!
Hurray! I did something.
What the fuck did I do?
seriously all I did was get it stuck
well this is stupid!
Try this ahh put your arms in the air!!
Be creepy and horrifying as fast as you can!
Haaaa boosky! yay I made it
Ohh that did it just enough do that I can DO THIIIIS!! *Markimoo noise* Yes..ok
that's good
Alright GOT IT 6x
oh!
ok!
Ahh finally up to my chateau! My isolated...place in the middle of the mountains, hello me
That beautiful face of mine and my weird, beard neck!
This takes a neck beard to a whole new level!
Ahh!
Yes!
My lovely home ding- ding dong
AAAHH!
WHY CAN'T I- oh it's a pull, nevermind
anyway
Everything A-ok
Just gonna- that's how I normally walk in my own door
Ahh good! my TV! I can relax! Didn't I see a tutorial where I flipped over couches in rage?
HUP!~
No I just wanted to redecorate a little bit God that face needs to stop getting so close!
*Terrifying music*
Ughh
Ok good
Ahh SHIT
My chateau betrayed me!
Ass-enoid!
Dammit...
OH! At least this time- oww- At least this time I had cushions
cushioning my fall
So am I gonna have to pull down these boards or do I just jump through the window here?
Heee Oh I'm struggling few titli-ti-titlish-ly...
Ha-boosky!
Oh goddammit there's glass!
I just wanted to give it a few swift humps before I was done!
*breathe*
Aaaahahaa I'm flailing in desperation
There's gotta be a way to pull these off right?
Maybe?
Maybe not?
*Marki noise* I'm givin' it all the- Ohh SHIT! My butt muscles are stronger than I ever thought they could be!
Alright then...
Get the other one here
HAAAA IT'S WORKING!
YAA!
oh man
twerked to destruction
ooh boy I get to make a big swinging metal thing go BANG!
SMASH IT
Well that did absolutely Jack-didly...What the frick I WASN'T EVEN LOOKING AND YA BLEW UP!
CAN YOU ACTUALLY DO THE DESTRUCTION WHEN I GOT MY FACE POINTED TOWARDS IT?
Alright whatever
Heh!~
Ahh rage against the machine take that couch cushions!
You sons of bitches!
ok...
alrighty then
Oh don't mind me I'm just... tryna...trust my body ever so gently up against things
*Marki silence*
what about you?
*Marki breathe*
Haaa boink?
No?
*Marki thinks*
*Marki noises*
no?
*Marki noises* *loud crash* Oh...that one worked! Ok!
I just needed to be more desperate about things
great!
good to know!
Why are these still up?
AAHHH Boink!~
Can I climb up here? No...?
Can I push 'em over?
No..?
Can I do anything with my life?
Great!
Happy to know where I stand when things are grim!
MR. GORVENCHAVE? GIVE ME A FRIKIN HAND HERE!
OK THERE WE GO GOT IT WOO! *laughs* I'm a rule breaker! I'm a rebel baby!
I'm gonna jump on that giant swinging ball (CAMEINLIKE AWRECKIINGBALL)
Cuz when I see balls...well that- THAT WAS EASY!
I DID IT!
OHH I DIDNT EVEN NEED TO TRY
OH IM THE GREATEST!
*truck noises* oh, hello, oh that's you, ok nevermind then
man this is another part of the human experience watching the degradation of society and everything we've built crumble to ash
around us, IS THIS WHAT YOU MEANT BY "HUMAN FALL FLAT"??
HUMAN CIVILIZATION FALL FLAT?
WONDER WHAT HAPPENED!
hello
is anybody here? *laughs* I hope! I hope! I hope there's another human here!
for me to enjoy the company of!
HAHAHAHAHAHAAAA
oh ok
oh good it's another dumpster that imma throw off the edge of the world!
goodbyye
I have a feeling I'm supposed to- waa I wasn't supposed to go with it!
OW!
Every non bone that I have has been shattered- and my leg is in this GODDAMMIT
LET GO! LET GO! HELP! POLICE!
SOMEBODY! Aisha Tyler!
Oh where did I go now? Well, good thing I got this ride! I'll never be alone again!
Now that I got my friend Dumpy here! Can I- can I please- could I- I don't know what's happening!
I don't know what's going on!
I don't know what I'm supposed to be doing
Kinda got Fuber-nucked here!
CAN YA LET GO OF MY GODDAMN ANKLE!
OR ANY GODDAMN SECOND! I'LL TAKE YOU WITH ME YOU BASTARD!
ANYWHERE YOU WANNA GO!
*Marki restarts*
Haaa boosky
*Marki noises* Oh shit, hehe whoops!
I wanna go on the big wheels fuck ow broke my everything
Ehhh ok OH FUCK YOU COME ON MAN!
*Marki noises* Me want up come on can I swing ball?
Me swing big ball me get momentum first...mmm
ok me-me get momentum
me momenting!
ok well that's not quite going as planned
ok now me I'm going to swing big ball
I'm going to- this- this is not fast
this is opposite of fast
any minute now!
and boink- that was just a warning
The love tap was meant to show my emotions
and now!
You're gonna get the full brunt from the other side oddly enough
THERE WE GO
I BROKE YOU FROM THE INSIDE
I GOT YOU ON MY SIDE AND THEN I SHOWED YOU WHAT WAS REALLY WHAT WERE!
AND NOW IM GONNA GET YA
what do I do with this?
what do I do with this box of crap?
AM I SUPPOSED TO GET THIS OVER THERE HOW THE HELL AM I SUPPPOSED TO DO THAT?
I CANT MAKE IT
IT AINT- IT AINT POSSIBLE!
I GIVE UP
*Screams*
oh made it nevermind then
Hu!~ Heh!~
SHIT I BROKE IT
Oh well
too bad I ain't paying for it
Hep!~ ok
COME WITH ME IF YOU WANT TO LIVE
COME WITH ME IF YOU'RE A BOX AND YOU DONT REALLY- oh SHIT I didn't even know that there was glass there
oh well that's just much- how much I don't care about society
Giving that there's no one else here
alrighty then
Where the hell am I going now?
if there was like any semblance of story to this, like, who am I?
why am I here and why was there a narrator taking about the human existence?
And, what seemed like the futility of human existence?
Ohhh I know what I need to do
I NEED TO DESTROY! I NEED TO DESTROY!
BREAK DOWN THE POLES OF SOCIATY!
AAAHHH
HEHE
Oh that almost smashed my face right open
oh well
*Marki thinks*
Ok open says me!
Open says me and you better stay open!
or else imma be very upset
Oh no, NO, NO, NOOOOO!
SHIT
open please?
Please open, maybe I could, wedge one of these in there
I seems like it might be designed for that EXACT idea
Ok let go of that thank you
ok almost got it
almost got it
Just gonna rub my groin up against it a little more
AAAAH I'm the strongest man in the world!
I'm the only man in the world!
IM NOT EVEN SURE IM HUMAN
can I- get this- a little- there we go
Stay that way, you better stay or I'm gonna come back and smile at ya
And no one likes that... *cough* *cough* Fangirls do *cough*
no one likes that
where is this goin?
and why is this goin? (that's what she said)
I needa get that box!
How do I get the box?
whats in the box?
The hell happened there?
Ahhh good enough whatever
Haaaa
Shit! I didn't- Nooo NOOO NOO!
Haa hangin on hang on let me really think about this before I do anything
i wouldn't wanna be too impulsive about saving my own life here!
Ahh made it ok
Hep!~ Beh!~
*Non-understandable Marki noises*
*Marki noises* I don't know how I'm gonna get this box back!
But I'm gonna try my best
*More weird Marki noises* Ahh shit
*Marki noises* OK!
Alright!
Now what?
I didn't think this one through
I'M OUTTA HERE BABY!
AHH!
ok everything's fine
*Incomprehensible Marki noises*
*Moans*
ok
*Now Mark's just being awkward noises*
I don't know how I'm gonna do this
HUP!~
oh i did it
congratulations being I'm the greatest there ever was
*More Marki noises*
AHHH
Oh fuck -Markiplier's last words
Ahh, not...the way I anticipated victory to be claimed
*Marki noises*
Oh, Oh god, ooooh God
Ohh God I don't wanna reset it, I don't wanna do it again!
I can make it! Oh I'm swinging more and more precariously! Aahhh this is a nightmare!
It's a goddamn nightmare!
GET UP THERE GODDAMMIT JUST GET UP THERE
YA SACK OF CRAP
Don't grab under there *cough* *cough* that's what she said *cough*
GRAB UP!
GRAB UP! Ahh fuck it
*screams*
did it reset it?
Oh good thank goodness gravy!
I don't know why I didn't just jump from up here
'cause I'm a frikin idiot
HAAA!~
Ahh made it didn't even need to grab on
HOOO!~
Ahh man I'm amazing
look at me
No human fallen flat here!
Human go through door!
Human claim victory!
Human don't know where I am
Where is human
hello?
I- I don't know if I was supposed to go this way
maybe there's clues to the story in the environment
wait a minute
WAIT A MINUTE
WAIT A MINUTE ISN'T THIS BACK WHERE I WAS??
WHAT THE F THIS IS BACK WHERE I WAS
GET UP THERE you can get up there
GET UP THERE
SACK OF CRAP
What is THAT gonna do for ya?
Why is there one more couch cushion up there?
what does it matter?
Hup!~
WHY DID I COME UP HERE
WHY DID I COME TO GET THIS this is a load of baloney here
Hup!~
Uhhh
I'm gonna take this with me, no I'm not
Screw this! Screw this noise
If I had known there was a secret around here I would've gone here in the first place
I don't even know if I can get back!
Ahhh titty-sprinkles!
MOMMY MOMMY
MOMMY AHH
SHIT
ahh crap
*burp* ahh crap
GET your other goddamn hand UP THERE! *that's what she said*
GET IT UP THERE YOU SASSY BITCH!
there we go, thank you for cooperating
*Marki silence* *Marki noises*
ok
So this seems important let me wreck this WELL
SHIT BALLS WHERE DID I GO?
OWW
THAT ALMOST HIT ME!
I GOTTA CLIMB UP THE DAMN THING AGAIN
WHAT A ASS
YOU BROKE IT YOU BITCH
oh well
I don't know what to do about this
Maybe I could throw one of these rocks at this wall and break it with my super strength
HABAA!~
no...?
try again
HABAA!~
NOO...??
One more time otta do it
HABAA!~
*loud crash*
Again
3 is the rule apparently
I did not expect that to work at any way but I'm much stronger than I anticipated
I don't even need todo this I can probably break it with my bare hands
Get outta here, get outta here
I SAID GET OUTTA HERE
uh oh, I shouldn't stand in the way of that
Would've made things a bit interesting
Yay physics!
Alrighty then, where am I going now?
obvioulsly not over here
'Cause I'm not gonna make this jump
HEBLEBFLEBRU!~ (I don't know what noise Mark made)
Nevermind I made it with ease
Oh shit
It's glass!
Who-da thunked it?
Who-da thunked?
You swing back here, nevermind, ahhhhh frack
I THINK IT BROKE ANYWAY!
JUST BECAUSE I WILL-ED IT, YES!
With my shear force of mind
Alrighty then I guess I...didn't need to do anything after all
I'm not an active participant in this game everything's just gonna happen without me-OHH GAHD!
OH GOD THAT'S GLASS OH SHIT-BAG-ASS-COCK
OWWW
EVERY PART OF MY BODY BLOWN!
ok this time it's not gonna suck
Yay didn't suck
*awkward Marki noises*
Easy bake oven
*Machine noises* Well that doesn't help me 'cause I don't have a thing
HABAAA!~
HUP!~
*sniff* *sniff* ok
So is there gonna be a form in any of that I can complain 'cause I'm pretty sure that this is against union laws
HELLOOOO?
ANYBODY HOME?
AAHH IM SO ANGRY
AHH PULL IT ALL DOWN
oh it's a door, nevermind then
I thought it was a breakable object
It probably was, but then again I put a- coulda realized that from the get-go
get outa my face, HAA!~
THATS WHAT YOU GET, I'LL BREAK IT ANYWAY
LIKE I GIVE A FUCK
Well shit I also came into a problem
Uhhh
Titty-sprinkles
ahh just slam that down in rage and then find a way to raise that bridge up
ok
Don't know here I'm going again but here I go
Ahhh sack-a-frack
Where am- where am me go?
Am me cross this?
That seem me right good
Maybe?
I don't know if I'm supposed to go across this
I am going to fall x7 YES I MADE IT
I made it to a broken area because- this pipe obviously isn't complete
HEP!~ I don't even know if I supposed to be up here
But this is good enough for me
YAY I DID IT
HUP!~
oh that was a ladder I could've just easily climbed that up
BUT I LIKE MY WAY BETTER HUP!~
Mmmm ok here we go
is this what I was supposed to do?
is this where I awas supposed to be?
probably not I don't even see a control up here
this seems like I'm not supposed to be here
Great
maybe I can just climb over it anyway
who needs this?
if I can just go on the pipe cant I just go around the entire level?
I mean who needs to go through this?
i certainly do NOT
Ahh shit
Hep!~ get up
Get- get that higher up
Hep!~ there we go
Ya I mean, I'm not gonna be one to mince words here I'm- OHH SHI- NAA *Marki noises* AND I WILL ALWAYS LOVE YOU
get up
thank you...ok
Back on top of things I'm not gonna fall like a goober
where the hell am i supposed to be
IM JUST GONNA bypass everything
don't mind me
I have a funny feeling I was probably supposed to use this at one point
and I just didn't do it at the right point
*sings happily*
can i get up there?
*Awkward Marki noises* Yay
ok good enough for me
How do I get outta there?
Maybe if I- if I just jump from the side
I'd be able to get around
But I have a funny feeling it's not gonna be too polite about that if I don't go about it the right way
Eeh!~
Maybe...? Almost...? Yay!
What does that do?
Ohh
That seems like it was supposed to do something
But then I didn't do it..so shit
Ahhh
Oh there's like a switch down there oh ok
Oh got it ok
so that did a thing
and that's good
maybe
come on go down here now
investigate this doo-dad whatever the hell IT does
oh GET OUTTA THE WAY GLASS!!!
son of a biscuit...NOPE
this does absolutely dick-didly there was no point to any of that
Ahh, OHH
I get it, I GET IT I GET IT, I Know I know I know I know
what I'm supposed to do
I know! I know what I'm supposed to do
I'm supposed to swing-swong
And if I swing enough swongs...
I'll make it through
ok so I just gotta get the physics of it
ITS JUST LIKE WHEN I WAS ON THE PLAYGROUND LONG AGO
AS A LITTLE CHILD even though this piece of glass is being shoved up my taint
GREAT
that getting in the way of my momentum
HATHAA!~ FUCK YOU! GET OUTTA THE WAY!
son of a bitch
SON OF A BITCH STOP IT
It keeps bonkin' the tips of my legs
STOP IT
GET OUTTA THE WAY
Hep!~
Ok ALMOST THERE
Almost there
Here we go!!
AAAHHH Fuck! Make it! AHH Goddamit!
FUCK ME IN THE BUTTHOLE
Stupid piece of glass is it outta the way yet goddammit
that son of a bitch glass
get outta here
GET OUTTA HERE
MOMMY MOMMY I WANT ANOTHER RIDE FUCK I missed mommy!
I broke my legs and got shards of glass in my teeth!
Here we go AHH
ok this time!
THIS time everything's gonna work out perfectly
No shards of glass in the way
Here we go
Almost!
Not quite!
Little more...
Daa!~
AHHH YES! oh I did it! ok! now we got it!
Goin' somewhere
don't know, holy shit, we're on missed
This is literally missed! I'm pretty sure we're on missed
Let me just get through here
I'm gonna bash you with this rock!
You shouldn't have given me a weapon!
Shit missed
Ya that's just a warning
HUP!~
Not a- Not quite
Habaa!~
Not happenin'
Nope, Eyy did it
Ok I'm gonna push open these doors and see what
Wonders-nevermind it's a pull again
Goddammit there's a little piece of lock in there
Is that really what's gonna stop me from escaping this?
This little piece of lock here
really? Is that how it's gonna work?
Ok! Got it! Alright!
NOW I shall SEE where I am
And what I fuck?
I shall SEE where I am
Oh Boy! I'm in another goddamn courtyard
Frick me
Ok here we go
NOW WE SHALL SEE whoa!
Hey...
Ok this is legitimately like Missed OHH do I get to toss myself in a catapult yes please!
Oh please tell me I can do that
I wanna do it! I wnna believe!
I really wanna believe make it in here...HUP!~
Shit...not quite..almost
So if I- if I crank this down a bit more...
Yaaa ok
Ya ok, alight, ok, alright, ok...alright...ok, HERE WE GO
3, 2, 1
5- 5, 7, 6
WOO!!
oh shit!
OWW
ALRIGHT!
So that's the end of Human Fall Flat for now there's obviously more stuff to be done
BUT I DONT KNOW IF I should continue let me know if you wanna see more
In the comments below, there's probably more interesting ways
to use as bizarre physics system
in the next few levels
SO THANK YOU EVERYBODY FOR WATCHING
AND AS ALWAYS...
I WILL SEE YOU!
IN THE NEXT VIDEO!
BA-BYE!
Captions done by TwilightFrost18
Special thanks to Mr. Markimoo for being amazing as always!
Hope this helps some of you! Byyeee!!!